I want to just tell you about
manifestation because it's effortless
it's light and it's effortless there's
no effort involved when you're fighting
when you're pushing you don't believe
that you have what you're wanting it's
not going to come you're going to keep
creating not having it because you're
creating all the time so you're either
manifesting it or you're creating not
manifesting it or the absence of it so
manifestation is like I once used to
think that it's as light as a feather so
there's this effortless feeling that you
have inside of you when you want to
manifest it's just like this feeling of
peace and happiness and you just know
that it's going to come and you know
that a single thought that you focus on
will manifest you have all power to
manifest whatever you want full power
and so if you don't believe in the power
that you have then you're going to
really push and pull ocean pool and
fight need motivation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Rhonda
Byrne and my take on her top 10 rules of
success
enjoy
rule number two discover who you truly
are everybody has regrets
but when you're free you don't regret
anything anymore
couldn't tell you I don't regret
anything because you realize that
everything LED you to the place of being
free and that's what everything in your
life is leaving you right now to the
place of you being free and realizing
your incredible true nature so
everybody has also experienced betrayal
of trust right I shall have multiple
times over really good at attracting
that
everybody's been burnt
life is not about those circumstances
life is about how you respond to those
situations
you know
just it's so important that you don't
blame anybody and you don't blame
yourself because I think a lot of the
time if we've suffered a betrayal deep
down we're kind of but we're blaming
ourselves for having fallen for it for
not having seen it you know and so right
at the root of it all we're kind of
we're blaming the other person but
really we're blaming ourselves don't
blame don't blame anyone you just
attract more circumstances where you
will blame so don't blame anybody don't
blame yourself this was an experience
that you had to have believe me I've had
them I am sure most of the people out
there have had all of those experiences
too it's no big deal guess what it's
part of life it's okay
um
so and especially
don't believe any thoughts from now on
that have anything to do with that
situation because once again it's only
the thoughts that are regurgitating it
it's if you have suffered some kind of
betrayal or an unjust situation it's
something in the past right it's not
here right now it's something in the
past and so just leave it it's gone just
let it go into the past and don't bring
it into your life now I just be like
or if you can be fresh
no fresh fresh of all of that baggage
fresh of all of those those burdens that
are in your mind just be fresh and clear
totally clear
so one of the things that I found
if you if you want to just um
sort of relax a little bit and you know
what I discovered this at in the dentist
chair
and I was having dental work done and I
noticed that I was like clenching like I
had my hands on the chat and I noticed
that I was clenching oh my oh and I'm
like look I'm pledging this contraction
right and so instead what I did was I
just opened the palms of my hands like
this like this well you know what you
really can't be tense
if you're opening the palms of your hand
and so for the rest of the appointment I
just stayed like that and I was super
super relaxed so there's just something
if you're feeling a little tense over
something is to just open your hands out
like that and the palms of your hands
open rule number three stay aware of
your thoughts I don't think many of you
would have that problem would you
at all no
um
the more aware you can be of your
thoughts
the less you're empowering negative
thoughts so it's really comes down to
your awareness and it doesn't matter
look if you go down a rabbit hole with a
whole lot of thoughts in your head and
and what matters is that you realize oh
my gosh I went down rabbit hole with all
those thoughts because every time you
can see that you followed thoughts
is your Awakening those thoughts and
you're you're weakening the grip of the
mind on you to to kind of hypnotize you
it's a feeling of like being hypnotized
isn't it when the thoughts are just
constantly constantly going in your head
so the more you become can become aware
of your thoughts
the less you Empower them and the Freer
you will become and you get to a point
where you are completely aware all of
the time and then your mind is in the
background
and thoughts just don't bother you and
instead you use your mind for what it
was meant for and what was it meant for
it was meant to
um it was meant to create whatever you
want in this world that's what the
mind's for rule number four overcome
pain you have to see the pain gone in
your mind to manifest it in the world so
just imagine what it would be like to be
free of all painful Sensations
and the other thing is you're also
identifying with depression because you
said I am chronically depressed
well you know the real you is not
chronically depressed but there is the
energy of depression in your body at the
moment so if you can if you can and this
is just a suggestion just an invitation
if you can instead say that the energy
of depression is passing through this
body okay if you have to say anything
I'm just trying to encourage you not to
label yourself with anything you don't
want and that goes for all of us look
sometimes I'll find myself doing it
giving myself a label I'm like what why
would I say that why would I say that
why would I stick that to me so don't I
just got this incredible image of
sticking all labels of everything we
want over it right like Happiness joy
intelligence
um Clarity Beauty I just got this
wonderful image of that
um
you were so powerful that you will keep
yourself in the place that you are
identified with or that you are
declaring that you are okay so you can
be free of your current situation but
you have to see it in your mind first
and then you will attract the
circumstances that set you free
the person continues on and this letter
I just I just feel helps me to
say a whole lot of things to people out
there that are suffering in pain okay so
no matter what that or or suffering with
depression or any kind of physical or
mental or emotional
difficulty that they might be facing the
person continues
um I'm exhausted from fighting to even
try to have a bit of a life my pain
is incurable
my depression getting to the highest
level
and so these words are really powerful
and there's nothing incurable in my
world there is nothing incurable I will
not accept that I know that the Universe
has infinite ways of freeing you from
this situation infinite there have been
so many miracles that have happened and
and something can happen for you too so
if you can just focus on the solution
and not on the problem and I know it's
not easy but to be free that's what you
need to do
that's what you've got to do there are
infinite ways you can be free of the
pain I don't care what anybody says and
so and you can have a great life
um even if you you say it was a car
accident even if you refer to memory and
go back and remember what it was like
before you had the car accident and just
use memory
to to just because for the law of
attraction or for the for the spiritual
laws there's no time and so those laws
don't know if you are thinking of
something in the past or if it is
something in the future or it's all now
for the spiritual laws so just see
yourself use memory and just see
yourself before you had the accident how
you felt and I really hope that that has
helped you a lot and anybody else that
might be suffering in that way also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five focus on what you
want I wanted to say this and I talk
about it in the sacred and we have been
so orientated toward action
that we that was one of the beliefs
remember that I said that we have to do
something to get something because you
can't get anything for nothing
so you definitely don't have to take
action
that is a world belief it really is it's
a world belief
um
so
I just want you to know that your focus
of what you want is more more is
stronger and more powerful than any
action you could ever take if you stay
focused for one minute on something you
want honestly it's like 10 years of
action so understand the incredible
mental power that you have to bring
about what you want in the world every
single thing you do in life
is following a thought you can't do
anything without having the thought
first of all to do it and so thought
always precedes everything else and so
and so if
and so in a nutshell
thought is more powerful than any action
you can ever take
and that should help you in your life to
just remember that rule number six live
a life of purpose first of all I want
you to know and I just offer this to you
that your purpose and everyone's
ultimate purpose is to realize who you
really are
um and after that life will place you
exactly where you are meant to be and
you will be living your purpose without
you having to have done anything
anything and it and that could be a life
of giving and service
um I know that for me doing these lives
just means everything to me to connect
with everybody I never imagined that
this is what I would be doing but I was
just I felt so inspired to do to do
these and um and so your purpose
when you can be free you life will take
you there it really will
um
and you will have a life that is full of
joy
and your life will become crystal clear
to you so let me just look back at the
question again
um your ultimate purpose is to realize
who you are and then
and then you will once you realize that
you will not have to do anything you
will be put in exactly the place that
you need to be put in and do you know
what when you talk about a life of
service
if you know who you really are you are
having the greatest effect on the world
beyond anything you could ever ever
imagine
because you are omitting all love and
all positivity and all joy and happiness
and we are all connected
and all of that is reaching everybody
across the planet so when you
have realized who you are then your
purpose just by your very existence will
be uplifting everybody else on the
planet rule number seven leave your
mistakes behind everyone makes mistakes
everyone that's life we all make
mistakes some of us make bigger ones
some of us make smaller ones but we all
make mistakes don't let your mistakes
Define Who You Are don't focus on them
leave them behind in the past because if
you're looking at mistakes what you're
doing is you're just regurgitating
memory through the mind you basically
reliving a mistake over and over and
over when it's something that happened
in the past and it's done where that's
gone and it's done with you're the only
one that can continue to perpetuate it
through here you know just by thinking
back and focusing on it so leave leave
it behind let it be gone let it be
something that's dead and gone and
buried and just move on just let it go
let it go and if the Mind throws up
throws up those things again then just
don't believe those thoughts just just
say I'm not interested if you don't
energize a memory it'll disappear
doesn't matter how traumatic it is if
you don't energize it it will completely
completely disappear
um I and one thing you could do if you
wanted to do this it's like create like
a ceremony if you feel I can't just let
it go just like that then you could
write out on a piece of paper mistake I
hope you don't write out too many but
write out on a piece of paper your
mistakes and you can have like a
ceremony of them burning that piece of
paper right or throwing that piece of
paper in the trash tearing it up into
little pieces and then throwing it in
the trash
so that you know that so that you really
feel that you're letting go of it please
don't Define Yourself by mistakes they
are not who you are they are not who you
are you know you're perfect you are
perfect and and in this experience of
the world we have imperfections
it's fine it's fine so what you know
just move on well number eight visualize
fully hi Rhonda whatever I want to
manifest something I will be giving that
thing my attention that's right you will
I get to see glimpses of the things that
I want to manifest after thinking about
them but they just glimpses they've
never truly manifested
so I guess if I want to manifest
anything I have to think about them with
the feeling that it's already in my
possession
if not they will just be glimpses and
not manifest am I right on this and this
is from Eden edham from Singapore
yes you are right in that you need to
feel as though you have your
manifestation in your possession for
sure I mean sometimes it's possible to
just think something and it manifests
too but if it's something we really want
we kind of need to pull in all of our
power right we need to bring in feelings
as well and really kind of get behind it
and and sort of supercharge it
um but I want to just say with glimpses
because I know what you mean by glimpses
but if you want you can interpret
glimpses as a sign of land that your
manifestation is about to arrive right
and you know a sign of land like Sailors
when they're out on the ocean and and a
sign of land would be seeing Twigs on
top of the water or something like that
or seeing some birds flying overhead
they would be signs of land they know
land is close by and so I would always
use
it glimpses as a sign of land and I
would be like
it's coming it's coming it's about to
arrive and so maybe that will help you
um maybe that will help you if you see
glimpses as as a sign that your
manifestation is about to arrive number
nine ReDiscover your confidence here's
the amazing thing you never lose your
power ever is impossible you can't lose
it but you can create or attract the
experience of not having power
that's the re that's how powerful you
are you are so powerful that you can
create not being powerful at all and so
you are powerful you're attracting every
single second of your life not just the
things that you want attractings and
things that you don't want to so
um probably the best thing to do if you
remember when you started you probably
started with something small if you're
feeling you're not attracting things
just go back and choose something small
because you don't have a lot of
resistance around something small like
if I say to you attract a cup of coffee
today
in your body you will feel oh yeah I can
do that I can do that whereas if I say
to you attract ten thousand dollars
today you'll be like you'll have
resistance so choose small things and
that will rebuild your confidence but
let me tell you you are all the power
there is and so whatever you say goes
even if you're saying I'm not powerful
and I've lost it so hope that helps for
anybody that might be kind of feeling a
little shaky about manifestation and
Rule Number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is practice
positive affirmations affirmations
inside them every day over every second
day depending on how quickly you want to
change life you can say them at night
just before you go to sleep or you can
say them in the morning and you know
what you can say them mentally or you
can say them out loud
sometimes it's good to feel try and feel
yourself which feels the most powerful
for you just saying them mentally or
saying them out loud I mean I came to
say them mentally but if you were saying
them mentally watch that the mind
doesn't just like skip over them what's
that you really really like giving them
a good emphasis but I mean I I still do
affirmations I do Health affirmations I
do all kinds of affirmations and
um and so they're just great you know
it's just a great thing to do
I want you to know that there's not
really any difference between you
walking around in this world here this
is for Law of Attraction no difference
to that or you imagining in your mind
there's no difference it doesn't know
any difference between the two so if
you're if you're visualizing it Law of
Attraction for Law of Attraction this is
something that you you already have
and and so if you're not really
believing it it just kind of means you
need to do it some more right and um and
and try and come up with some scenarios
that are really believable to you like
one of the things I would always do to
manifest and I don't know why it just
worked for me I defaulted to this I
would I would imagine I would imagine
telling somebody what I manifested that
it had already manifested so I would
imagine those phone calls I would
imagine talking to a friend I would
imagine people saying you know saying to
me wow how did you get that where did
you get that so that was really
believable to me but if because if you
really want something then you're going
to want to share it with family and
friends and and so that really worked
incredibly well for me so maybe that
might work for you give that a try doubt
this comes from the mind
and they're just thoughts and and
they're the reason that they're
appearing is because you have a belief
that is saying that you don't have this
already but just don't give those doubts
any any energy and work harder on
feeling that you have your manifestation
because when you believe you have your
manifestation no thoughts of Doubt will
come when you believe you have it you
have overridden any other belief in the
subconscious mind you've reprogrammed
your subconscious and then it will
manifest so just remind yourself that
you are the power
that creates everything
lastly effortlessly you were that power
so so just
take it it's not it's not an effort it's
really easy you know it's really easy
just take it easy let go of the let go
of the doubtful thoughts when we reject
the negative thought are we creating
resistance
we could be it depends how you're
rejecting it if you just if you're just
kind of letting it go and not
identifying with it and not believing it
then it's not going to create any
resistance but if you wish it wasn't
there but if you wanted to go away and
you fall like that about it then you are
creating resistance and the next part of
Leslie's question is to welcome a
negative thought stops resistance that's
true but are we manifesting that
negative thought and letting it into our
subconscious by welcoming it are we
manifesting the negative thought when we
welcome a negative thought
so no it won't manifest and the reason
it won't manifest is because we're not
believing it because when we welcome it
we've noticed what it is we're not
believing it we're not identifying with
it and it won't manifest thoughts only
manifest when we believe them when we
identify with them so welcoming not only
releases the negative thought it takes a
whole lot of negative thoughts out of
the subconscious mind with it so I mean
it's all it's a really incredible my
teacher would say it's an automatic
self-cleansing mechanism
so all we have to do is just kind of
welcome that negative thought or welcome
that negative feeling and it's basically
cleaning out everything and as it does
you get lighter your life becomes
spectacular you become so happy nothing
bothers you anymore you don't even
understand what the word problems means
it's some alien word that other people
must experience but you don't see a
problem with anything anywhere unlike is
just incredible and your body feels
amazing so
um so it's worth it yeah it's worth it
but you are not going to manifest that
thought
when you are welcoming it how do we
break that negative thought pattern
right so so you I mean the mind is like
a computer program so and and the fact
that it's on a negative Loop is because
we programmed it on a negative Loop but
but you know we could have been
influenced when we're children and
things like that so
um so one of the things that the Mind
loves his loves repetition I mean he
loves it you know if you really watch
your thoughts this is the same old
thoughts over and over again you know
it's just kind of dishing up the same
old thing so it loves repetition so the
way you can override a program is to put
in the opposite you know and when you
start out you know you feel like you're
lying you know you'll say something like
you know you might be really broke gee I
was when I was making the secret so
um you might not have any money and
you're trying to instill you know wealth
and prosperity and riches and every time
you say it you feel a contraction in
your body because you know you don't
have it but you know truly because I did
it myself after a while you change it
you re you really begin to change it and
you don't quite have that contraction
anymore and then you start to see money
coming in you know in in different ways
um and any and and or you can be given
things that you were going to buy and
now you don't have to buy it or so you
begin to see you start to see lines of
land you know is one of the great one of
the great new thought thought writers
would say talk about a sign of land so
you start to see sign of land now that's
what I did in the secret you can do
gratitude that will turn everything
around that will make you feel good that
will get you off the negative rant
but those negative thoughts are coming
from beliefs held in the subconscious
mind right that's where the beliefs stem
from for most of us they stem mostly
from our childhood
conditioning yeah somebody's our parents
said something to us we just swallowed
it pokline and zinker you know we're
like right that's a belief and uh and so
we take it in and and then we have all
these beliefs that that uh and you can
hear you know if you if you're talking
to somebody like if if somebody says oh
I believe
or because we say that all the time or
somebody says I think
behind those two
behind those two statements are going to
be a belief and so the really
interesting thing they're hard to spot
because you believe they're true
yeah you don't think they're a belief
you think they're real you know and so
they can be hard to spot but if you
start to listen to yourself you know I
believe or I think or especially look at
the things that you have really strong
opinion about
because where you have a really strong
opinion is a belief that's underneath
that
so so one of the things that in the
latest book is that I show how to
um show how to dissolve those those
beliefs and just really by some of the
things that I've just mentioned and uh
and and you can dissolve them and you
just feel free every time a belief goes
out you feel completely free you know
it's it's amazing amazing feeling to you
just feel as light as a feather and
actually you feel Invincible I love
going with the flow
I really do because I have found that
life will present to me
manifestations far greater than I could
ever imagine with my mind and so I'm
really just these days letting
everything go because life does a way
better job than me
um I can't even think of things that are
more fantastic than what life does in
The Greatest Secret
uh it is explained that there's only
three kinds of thoughts and they are
comparing describing and measuring every
single thought you have fits into one of
those three categories and all Minds
behave this way all minds are comparing
measuring and describing every single
one of us we're not unique you know
we're not unique we've all we've all got
the same Smorgasbord of thoughts to to
kind of play with
um so but but the thing is it doesn't
with those thoughts it doesn't matter
what the Mind does
what matters is that you don't believe
those thoughts right
you just you don't want to identify with
those thoughts and don't believe them
you don't need to control them be trying
to bash them down with a hammer go go no
you don't have to do any of that you
just need to be observing and witnessing
them and that's the moment that you
observe a thought you were no longer
identified with that thought or
believing that thought and it can't
manifest you just like stop
manifestation in its tracks for a
negative thought so it's really perfect
um The More You observe and don't
believe thoughts the quieter your mind
will become
um and I talked before about thoughts
are not personal so they you know
they're just looking for someone to
energize them and just say be on your
way you're not you don't belong here I'm
fabulous I'm the infinite being I don't
want anything I don't want any negative
thoughts be on your way you just have to
let go of all the attachments to your
desires okay
when we let go of all our attachments to
desires guess what happens all our
desires manifest because when we don't
have attachment to our desires we don't
have resistance
and so I don't know that
I I try to think if I have if I have
many desires anymore I just love
everything the way life is just the way
it is even the tricky stuff even the
curly stuff even the sticky stuff it's
all just kind of fine but I don't have
an attachment to the way it's going to
work out because I know that everything
is fine I know we're all safe I know
we're Eternal I know there's no end to
any of us I know we're having an
adventure we're having a human
experience
and it's interesting at times isn't it
and it's fantastic at other times I
actually look at the world and I think
it's incredible I really think it's
something else
um but I don't get so perturbed I don't
get perturbed by all of those things
it's just anymore and so if you don't
have attachment
um to things then can life is really
really great actually
um attachments that kind of hurt us
um okay Jill is saying what do you mean
by attachment to your desires okay
so attachment is like when I really
really want something and I've really
really got to have it it's something
that you really really want and I've
really got to have it and I want it and
I can't be happy until I have it I just
life isn't going to be good until I have
it that's like an attachment to your
desire whereas if you were like
um
wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be nice wouldn't it be nice
to have a new house
okay so here's the difference I really
really want a new house I can't stand
this house this house is falling down
this house has a lot of problems and
then
on the other side of that is wouldn't it
be nice wouldn't it be nice to have a
new house
Can You Feel the difference this one has
is effortless it's kind of effortless
wouldn't it be nice so you could say
that in front of all of you all of your
um desires wouldn't it be nice if I had
this wouldn't it be nice and so that
you're not kind of attached
because when you're attached it's really
hard for it to manifest okay
so in the greater sacred I talk about
attachment
um I do a whole section on it and I do
it because it's important
um because you can have whatever you
want but attachment is something
attachment is
attachment is full of fear
fear that you're not going to have it
um uh you you can love somebody
and then you can be attached that you'll
be afraid of losing them you say love
isn't afraid of anything
attachment is afraid of losing losing
something
so that's kind that's kind of the
difference but if you if you just say
wouldn't it be nice you know then it's
like really easy going I mean you've got
a magic wand you can create anything you
want but you just got to be really cool
about it right you got to be I can do
that I can have that I can be that the
welcoming practice sounds
counter-intuitive that you would welcome
something right that you don't want it's
like whoa hang on a minute that doesn't
make any sense it does when I explain
this to you is that what when something
that we don't want appears we resist it
and if you remember in the secret what
you resist persists
and so if you're resisting something you
don't want it will never go away
welcoming is the opposite to resisting
welcoming stops you from resisting
that's why it's so brilliant
because resistance is
not them really
um but
even that idea of resistance not being
Fab is something to welcome that thought
is something to welcome and just welcome
that thought and then that thought
will completely dissolve instead of
building up inside of you and the mind
saying yeah resistance isn't any good
yeah you know the mind adding a whole
lot of other thought a whole lot of
other thoughts so that's a perfect
example of welcoming now what I did just
then because I've welcomed for the last
four years what I did just then I felt
it completely dissolve in my chest that
thought I'd that feeling that was behind
that thought just completely dissolved
and now that is gone
so it's it's it's that easy
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules for Marie forleo
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there you've got to
take responsibility for the energy that
you allow in your life I want you to
fend off negativity as much as humanly
possible you know we know so much more
about the brain than we did just 20
years ago